. Hey, here's an interesting voicemail.
You can call me at two one nine two.
David P. Here is a guy saying, how can I be
calling for unity now when I was against the
things Donald Trump did when he was elected?
This guy misunderstands my position.
But let's take a listen.
Yeah, hi, I got a question, I'm listening
to your show today, it's Monday, the 25th
you told me something about unity is a little
interesting.
We were saying unity four years ago when Trump
is president.
I mean, I don't understand.
Are you saying you want unity now?
But back then, you're everything you did you
were against.
No, no, no, no.
I am not the ones demanding unity.
I'm the one saying anyone thinking there will
be unity doesn't understand what's going on.
And so this is a very, very important thing.
I, I was not hypocritically demanding unity
in 2016 and or or ignoring it then and then
now calling for it back in 2016.
I was clear, listen, Trump won and I'm going
to oppose the things he does if I think they
should be opposed.
Joe Biden now won and we know that we aren't
going to see any unity from the right.
Joe Biden is asking for unity.
Some Republicans are asking for unity, even
though for them the definition of unity.
Is Biden not doing anything different than
Donald Trump?
I'm not the one calling for unity.
I'm the one pointing out it's not going to
happen.
So that's certainly a misunderstanding.
We've got a great bonus show today.
We will talk about control of the Senate.
We will talk about Harriet Tubman on the 20
dollar bill that is back in the news.
We will talk about Trump's second impeachment
trial, get instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at Join Pakman dot com.